BRIAN: SHOCKING IMAGES FROM
INSIDE A CRAMPED BORDER.
THIS CAME THROUGH YESTERDAY.
IF YOU HAVEN’T SEEN IT, DON’T
BLAME YOURSELF, IT JUST CAME
OUT.
>> THIS THE FACILITY IN DONNA,
TEXAS, SHOWING MIGRANTS STACKED
WALL-TO-WALL MANY UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN JUST SITTING THERE
LAYING THERE WAITING TO BE
PROCESSED.
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN BRIAN BABIN
AND RETIRED ACTING ICE DIRECTOR
TOM HOMAN TOURED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TOGETHER.
JAY JOINS US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY SAW BECAUSE THEY SAW A
LOT MORE THAN JUST THESE IMAGES.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU ARE NO STRANGER
TO THIS AREA, WHAT WAS DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS VISIT?
>> WELL, IT’S OUT OF CONTROL.
YOU KNOW, I MEAN, IN SPITE OF
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
TELLING US, THIS IS NOT A CRISIS
EVEN.
IT’S JUST A CHALLENGE, ET
CETERA.
WE KNOW IT’S A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS NOT ONLY FOR THE MAKINGS
THAT ARE COME IN.
MY HEART WENT OUT TO SOME OF
THESE CHILDREN IN A FACILITY
THERE IN DONNA THAT SHOULD BE
HOLDING 250 THEY HAVE 5700
PEOPLE STACKED IN THERE LIKE
SARDINES.
AND THEY JUST DON’T SEEM TO
REALIZE WHAT IS GOING ON THERE.
THE BORDER PATROL AS TOM WILL
TELL YOU OR I THINK THE MORALE
IS DOWN.
THEY ARE DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB
BUT THEY ARE BATTING WITH A
SHORT STICK.
AND THEN OPENING UP THE BORDERS
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND ABSOLUTELY CREATING THIS
PROBLEM AND PUTTING AMERICANS IN
DANGER AS WELL AS THESE
MIGRANTS.
AND THE STUNNING COST OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE.
BRIAN: I KNOW.
>> IT’S JUST UNBELIEVABLE,
BRAIN.
BRIAN: GETTING HOTELS,
CONVERTING MILITARY BASES TAKING
OVER CONVENTION CENTERS NOT EVEN
TELLING THE GOVERNORS.
TOM, IT TAKES A LOT TO
RATIONALIZATION YOU FROM WHAT
YOU SAW.
WHERE DOES THIS RANK IN
OUTRAGEOUS SCENES AT THE BORDER
IN YOUR CAREER?
>> IT’S THE WORST.
BECAUSE THIS WAS TOTALLY
PREVENTABLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
INCOMING ADMINISTRATION SAID IF
YOU END THESE PROGRAMS, WE ARE
GOING TO SEE A SURGE LIKE HAVE
YOU NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THEY WERE BRIEFED BY LEADERSHIP
AT ICE, AT CBP.
I TALKED TO PEOPLE THAT BRIEFED
THEM.
SO THEY KNEW THIS HAPPENED.
BRIAN, JULY OF LAST YEAR SAYING
THIS WOULD HAPPEN AT THE END OF
THESE POLICIES.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
AGAIN, THIS ISN’T INCOMPETENCE.
THIS ISN’T BAD MANAGEMENT.
THIS IS OPEN BORDERS.
THEY DESIGNED AN OPEN BORDERS
AGENDA AND THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE BORDER PATROL FEEL
ABANDONED, THEY ARE NO LONGER
ENFORCING THE LAW THEY ARE
FACILITATING ILLEGAL ENTRY AT
THE INSTRUCTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
BRIAN: YOU WERE TELLING ME
BEFORE THEY FEEL ABANDONED.
YOU USED THE WORD SURGE.
YOU OFFENDED A CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM QUEENS ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
HERE’S WHAT I’M TALKING ABOUT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, JUST GUT CHECK,
STOP.
ANYONE WHO IS USING THE TERM
SURGE AROUND YOU, CONSCIOUSLY IS
TRYING TO INVOKE A MILITARISTIC
FRAME.
THIS IS NOT A SURGE.
THESE ARE CHILDREN AND THEY ARE
NOT INSURGENTS.
AND WE ARE NOT BEING INVADED.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN, HOW DARE YOU
INSULT HER BY USING THE WORD
SURGE.
>> WHERE IS SHE NOW, BRIAN?
WHY ISN’T SHE DOWN HERE?
I CAN TELL YOU LEADING THIS
DELEGATION OF TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
AND FORMER PROFESSIONALS IN THIS
VERY BUSINESS, WE ACTUALLY ASKED
AFTER VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS WAS GIVEN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER SITUATION BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN WE ACTUALLY INVITED HER.
WE INVITED HER TO COME AND VISIT
WITH US AT SOME OF THESE SPOTS
ON OUR ITINERARY.
WE HEARD NOTHING WHATSOEVER.
AND ABSOLUTELY WHILE THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS TELLING US TO
CONTINUE TO WEAR MAVERICKS AND
ONLY VISIT WITH JUST VERY FEW
PEOPLE UP UNTIL JULY, THEY ARE
STACKING PEOPLE WHO ARE COVID
POSITIVE.
BRIAN: UP.
>>YUP.RELEASING THEM PUBLIC TO F
ACROSS TEXAS AND THIS UNITED
STATES IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
THEY HAVE -- IT’S JUST HARD TO
COMPREHEND HOW THEY CAN JUSTIFY
THIS EXCEPT THAT I THINK THIS IS
THEIR PLAN.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT AS MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE TO COME IN AND GET ON
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE AND BECOME
VOTING CITIZENS OR AT LEAST
VOTING, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE THAT
WOULD COME AND CONTINUE THE
DEMOCRAT MAJORITY.
AND I THINK PEOPLE JUST NEED TO
WAKE UP.
AND IF IT WASN’T FOR PEOPLE LIKE
YOU, BRIAN, AND FOX NEWS THEY
WOULD NOT BE GETTING THE TRUTH.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED IS THE TRUTH
HERE.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
TOM, YOU INSULTED HER WHEN YOU
USED THE WAR LIKE TERM SURGE.
>> SHE NEEDS TO COME DOWN AND
TALK TO THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PUT THE UNIFORM ON EVERY DAY.
BRIAN: SHE CAME DOWN WHEN TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BUT YOU HAVEN’T SEEN HER SINCE.
LOOK, THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
BORDER PATROL SAY IT’S A
SURGEON.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER
PATROL SAY IT’S A CRISIS.
PATROL KNOW AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID THAT THESE CARTELS ARE
USING THESE CHILDREN AND FAMILY
UNITS TO THROW THEM ACROSS THE
BORDER AND TIE UP ASSET.
40% NO LONGER ON THE LINE.
THESE CARTELS ARE MOVING DRUGS
AND BAD PEOPLE THROUGH UNGUARDED
AREAS.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
AND IF SHE CAN’T UNDERSTAND THAT
OR ACCEPT THAT THEN SHE
SHOULDN’T BE IN CONGRESS AT ALL.
BRIAN: IT’S UNBELIEVABLE IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS GIVEN THIS
PORTFOLIO CLEARLY BY THE
PRESIDENT, SHE TAKES THE WEEKEND
OFF AND SAYS I’M NOT GOING TO
THE BORDER.
I’M GOING TO THE ORIGIN OF WHERE
THE PROBLEM IS.
I DON’T KNOW, WHO IS MORE
POWERFUL IN THAT ADMINISTRATION?
IT’S HARD TO KNOW.
I DON’T EVEN KNOW WHAT SHE IS
DOING, BUT IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT THAT WOULD BE -- YOU WOULD
WANT THE JOB AND THEN NOT DO THE
JOB.